did you get the right ideas during that
thing i wouldn't say so because
i was i played the same move that i was
going to play after after one minute
actually i did the same i suggested
rookie 8 and then
at the end 40 minutes later we realized
it was the best yeah
oh it's a bit it's a bit strange that
this is a theoretical position
with white to move because people used
to play this line with the pawn on h3
like yes they used to play this d6
um d6 c3 uh sorry d6 h3 and then knight
a5 and d5
um
but yeah i
realized that even the tempo of my
position is
probably not great um what would white
usually play with the extra tempo if you
didn't have time for the piano i mean
some queenie two maybe okay we need to
yeah
i don't know
um yeah but the thing is i mean i don't
have any
even semi-useful wedding moves there so
what we're considering sorry we were
considering b4 yeah i just didn't see
why why yeah
um
maybe i i just thought it'd weaken my
position more than
than his
maybe there are some concrete
justifications there so
yeah but this
knight she was a relief to me
uh because i mean it's the move i
expected him to make because it forces
great simplifications but i thought dc5
was
very
very good here
so i take with the bishop he goes knight
g4 still
and
now it takes h takes
um
bishop e3 maybe your bishop
i could go bishop d6 also
but then i think g5 is strong stop being
queen do you think white is better yeah
i think white is just
comfortable with that one
so you you would have taken right
side more in this position
yeah maybe i have some b4 counter play
but it looked very
very iffy uh and if i trade everything
on e3
then i probably have to go knight c4 in
order not to lose a pawn and that's just
um a sad position so all of my time
spent was just trying to find find a way
to um after dc5 uh yeah to avoid these
things and then i
i
finally i came up with i'm i don't have
anything better
uh let's hope that he goes 94
immediately
and he did so after that what the
what was actually yeah no i think the
position is just equal um
after after this
uh yeah takes takes knight c3
this is all pretty
pretty normal rookie two is a nice move
preparing q1 later
um
here i mean i almost considered taking
an e3 because i didn't think i was
better at all
but were you surprised that he was so
eager to exchange rooks yeah that was
surprising to me that i mean that was
the main reason why i was hesitant to
play knight
d6 was that he could
yeah he could occupy the
the c file in some way also queen b4
looks decent
oh maybe not queen before because then i
get a5 and
b4 but
there i think that you have many good
options but what do you think maybe d5
somehow get something to c6
yeah
but i thought about it too then i'll go
i go a5 b4 and try to
i mean i'm always getting my knight to
e4 so yeah i feel like i i felt like it
was okay here
uh
clearly no no but like okay in the sense
that it's not
it's not worse yeah because i mean
that's the only reason why you wouldn't
play knight d6 but night after night d5
95 then there is no discussion that you
can get worse it's only you who can get
better yeah for sure um
so but here i was i thought knight
before was
like concretely because 93 is really
it's really passive
what's the idea after queen b6 or yeah
queen b6 i think he's getting
i mean there are several ideas queen bee
queen f3
is one queen e5 is also
not 25 just a five
a5 here
knife d5 95 28
yeah but i don't like that knight goes
back to 63 or something i feel like by
the version of the game yeah
the the queen is really
yeah
yeah it's really strong in e5 knight e3
for instance yeah
it's not even it's not even close um
i mean my intention was actually to go
queen e7 just to try and spook him but
i i don't think to give the a6
yeah i mean it takes takes knight five i
get it back
so what was the turning point later on
yeah now here
i feel like i'm
i'm already happy that i can play a
little bit
what did you think about this
didn't love a3 um i thought when i saw
a3 that that's going to be taken
but if i don't play three she has to
reckon with a5b
at this point he already has to make
some some small choices and that's
that's um
that's a very good thing for me one
thing that he should have done at some
point is to
uh for some reason after queen d3 i
spent like eight minutes calculating
queen c6
um
which is
not probably the best way to spend your
time
um
so the thing is if he doesn't play d5
then i'm achieving something i'm getting
a lot of space here yeah so he has to
play d5 i think
um
and then queen c1
not f1
so here i was thinking of
yeah knight d6 i couldn't make that work
because he goes
uh he goes queen deep
in e5 or can be said
probably and i thought he could just
take an a6 because
knight d2 is protected
yeah protecting both both of them so
oh queen a3
okay that probably works
oops
oh well it was uh i told you the a34
will be taken yeah
you see it happens in the most
unexpected situations
wow yeah i spent all this so maybe
that's your time well you just changed
your mind changed my mind okay then i
should definitely have gun queens since
six
wow
okay so you went 90s yeah you didn't
ruin anything in the game right but
um yeah i guess um yeah queen f6 was
really i was really happy with that that
was that was a tricky
tricky move
but do you think in this position
yeah i thought you would take yeah i
wasn't sure about this at all
um there was also knight b3
which is not i think insane
takes knight b4
not before but my king is coming really
quickly
king e1 king d6
sorry king of one king d6 king e1
you can reach to c4 i go to c4 maybe
it's just lost
you think it's lost already yeah should
be
yeah it can be three
i don't think you said yeah it should be
lost yeah
i mean these positions are usually lost
yeah
night ending so you think after knight
c4 it's lost already no no no it was not
clearly
not necessarily
i didn't like b4 what was your plan on
that
no i understand that the you were
already very optimistic yeah i was very
optimistic here uh i was
also i was under five minutes so i could
stop writing the most and just focus on
making them but yeah knight e3 it was a
blunder right it's a blunder but i mean
it's it's that lost i think
also if it doesn't go knight e3
he's already i think d5 is
really weakening so i can probably just
go round up
with your king also yeah
yeah i mean i have such a big positional
advantage at this point that i cannot
imagine that he can halt
well congratulations i want to ask you
one thing about yesterday's game it was
such a brilliant
end game well it wasn't possible to win
king e5 how did it come to your mind um
when did you point it out that this
incredible opportunity uh no i mean i i
uh
frankly i hadn't seen it before i went
to h5
but the h5 was my only chance anyway i
was just hoping that
you know i could
but the thing is i have to be honest
like i i didn't see
that he couldn't wait
so all this talk of brilliancy is like
he was thinking for a very long time i
didn't understand why
and then he played that f4 you mean
no when before yeah after age five right
no even after age five because i didn't
see that the pawn ending was winning
this was the point and he evidently saw
it because he was spending so much time
and so i mean in retrospect i feel like
a complete fool um because i was sitting
there he was thinking so long i didn't
understand why and i didn't understand
why he gave me these winning chances
while as a matter of fact like he
actually went for the only plan to to
make a draw and you just miscalculated
later
did you feel that you have any chance to
win the game you just seem to be
enjoying it a lot i wouldn't say i was
enjoying it too much um but
um
i think from from the opening uh if he
plays this way
this bishop ending is my only only
chance
um
but i didn't feel like there were great
chances because i thought like he could
put this king he could change the
the c pawns um put the king on c7 and
just wait like on f6 hc6 yeah no
yeah f6h6 g7 i thought that was a
fortress
but i mean you don't he if he plays like
this he cannot
avoid the king coming to c5 so it looks
very very
suspicious but i think it was a fortress
it was amazing for us to see sorry it
was amazing to us to see well okay it's
true it's like oh i got kinky five
yeah i know there's king e5 but then
things have already gone wrong for him
like he has one
um he has a few minutes left yes he has
one move that makes a draw and it's not
even obvious that no that was awfully
difficult
yeah bishop f1 and viciously no but i i
mean i
i'd seen it because i think
i thought it was his only chance i
didn't i didn't know for sure but
whether it was a draw but i thought it
was only a chance to you so bishop of h3
yeah yeah wow that was
because bishop g4 doesn't work because
like losing because i get the tempo with
the king yeah e3
yeah
but
so by process of elimination he has to
go bishop h3
because i don't know what he missed in
the game maybe he missed bishop d5 he
was hoping for some bishop g2 king e6
which paid three king d5 king
c4 but like after bishop d5 it just
resigns so that was a bit weird but
anyway um tomorrow is what matters yeah
so yeah magnus two classical wins two
nice grinds in a row how are you feeling
about tomorrow um
i'm i mean
i i'm never pessimistic about my chance
to win with uh with white but obviously
considering the form he's in
it's going to be going to be hard but
i'm going to
going to to try of course
uh and
yeah i mean
just the fact that i i have
i have a chance um i'm very
very happy about that was not obvious
after the game against crack
sure but let's say these two uh they've
got two grinds i mean two games that you
win by working very hard is that is that
gratifying or are you more troubled by
nagging thoughts about things that
you're unhappy about
um
no i wouldn't say it's particularly
gratifying it's more
it feels more like
as you say i'm working
i i'm not like
able to outplay my opponent so i i am
the only way i can win by working
very very hard so i wouldn't say
it's
i wouldn't say that it feels like a
great
accomplishment but i mean it's the thing
you sometimes need to do to turn
that tournament around
well you are still within striking
distance but
so far the big star has been richard
robert
what are your thoughts about about his
performance so far
are you impressed is it something that
you are
kind of surprised by in any manner or
yeah i mean i didn't expect him to be an
unbeaten plus four that's for sure um
but
what can you do yeah he's played
he's played really um he's played really
well and frankly he was
also much better against karjakin in his
first game so it's not like he's taking
all his chances either and he was really
pragmatic against me in the first
first game um
which i think speaks to
to the fact that he came here to to win
nothing nothing else and
yeah
i just have to to play a good game
tomorrow that's that's all i got but do
you think that's it that he came here to
win or i mean it he suddenly got into
this flow and things well i mean he kind
of he's not good enough to just come
here to win and win on demand obviously
but so
um he's a strong player so yeah he um he
has a chance and
yeah if he can survive tomorrow he'll
win the tournament
we are very much looking forward to that
fight congratulations for your win today
yesterday and good luck for here
tomorrow thank you thank you